Narrator: The National Library
of Medicine proudly presents:
Farmtastic Plastic.
Starring Polly Mer.
Join her on the farm
to help build plastics.
Olivia: Time for
Environmental Games!
I love these free games!
Polly Mer: Join me and help
earthlings make good choices
about plastics.
Welcome to Farmtastic Plastic.
Our mission is to collect the
goods to make plastics here on
the Plastic Farm.
Get Pickin'.
Olivia: Um, these
aren't tomatoes?
Polly Mer: This
is a plastic farm!
Those are monomers, or single
chemical molecules used to build
long molecules called polymers.
Olivia: So all of these
are different monomers!
There are so many types!
Polly Mer: Monomers are the
building blocks of plastics.
They are used to make
different types of plastics.
Let’s collect some.
Don’t forget the gold!
Yeehaw!
We have collected enough
types to earn a star!
Narrator: Expand your Farm!
Collect 3 styrene, 3 isocyanate,
and 3 polyethylglycol
Olivia: So much
for free gaming.
Polly Mer: Let's check
out that patch over there.
Olivia: These are big ones!
Polly Mer: Yes.
Monomers can be simple or
complex - these monomers are
larger molecules
with more atoms.
Olivia: Ethylene
oxide and Bisphenol A!
Styrene and
Dimethylteraphthalate!
Narrator: Want to build faster?
Get more monomer baskets!
Polly Mer: Sounds like
a pretty good deal to me!
Olivia: Pushy aren’t they?
Looks like we’ve filled
our basket again.
Narrrator: Congratulations!
You've unlocked the
Polymerization Mill!
Olivia: Polymers?
Polly Mer: Polymers are just
long chains of monomers that are
chemically connected
through covalent bonds.
Covelant bonds are the strongest
bonds between atoms.
Olivia: Um, they
won't connect!
Polly Mer: That’s right!
Remember – plastics are
SYNTHETIC polymers,
made of monomers combined
through a chemical reaction,–
not naturally occurring in
nature – but made by humans.
Humans discovered how
to make plastics in 1856.
Olivia: Okay- but how do we
get them to stick together?
Polly Mer: It depends!
Polymerization reactions
need heat, pressure, or
the presence of a catalyst,
another chemical, in order to
connect the monomers
together to form polymers.
Olivia: So that’s why we
need the Polymerization
Reaction Mill– it provides
the things needed to
combine the monomers
into polymers!
Polly Mer: Let’s try it.
This one is using the catalyst
Titanium (III) chloride to
speed up the reaction –
grab some ethene monomers!
Olivia: Wow- ethene monomers
are expensive to produce!
Narrator: Polymerizing
Olivia: Ugh! We have to wait.
Polly Mer: Time to browse
the Monomer pellet catalog!
Limited edition monomers -
Only $1.99.
Olivia: I thought my Biology
teacher told me we have polymers
in our bodies – we don’t have
plastic in us though, do we?
Polly Mer: (laughing)
No Plastic.
We do have NATURAL polymers–
occurring in nature without
human intervention- things
like DNA, Protein, and
polysaccharides,
a type of sugar.
These are all natural
polymers made of various
natural monomers.
They require cellular energy
and enzymes to catalyze those
polymerization reactions.
Narrator: 1 hour sale!
Olivia: Yeah, nothing predatory
going on here at all...
Look! It's done!
Olivia: Oh look- they are
all stuck together now-
I can’t pull them apart!
Oh I see- the double bonds
from the monomers are now
just single bonds!
That’s how the monomers
were able to stick together:
the double bond in the
monomer is broken and
a single chemical bond is
formed between the monomers.
Polly Mer: Yep- a
covalent bond- very strong.
This is polyethene sometimes
called polyethylene.
Even though it’s a polymer
now, it’s named after
the monomer molecule ethene.
Olivia: But what if I used
a different monomer?
Polly Mer: You’d make
a different polymer.
Polymers can be made of only one
type of monomer – or different
repeating types of monomers.
Olivia: Wait a second –
this is just like a string-
how is this plastic??
How does this hold soda pop?
Narrator: Come play in
our other game world!
Poly Mer: Plastics, as most
people think of them—soda bottles,
furniture, phone cases—are just
lots of those little strands
next to each other.
How they are held together
though defines the two
Thermoplastics and Thermosets.
Thermoplastics are sheets of
polymer strands held together
through weak
intermolecular bonds.
When heated – the strands
separate – the plastic melts,
and can be remolded
into different shapes.
These types of plastics
can be truly recycled
into something else.
Thermoset plastics – are held
together through strong covalent
chemical bonds between the
molecules of one strand and
another-created through a
process called cross-linking--
this makes a very strong matrix
that won’t melt when heated.
It also means that you
can’t make a new item
out of those plastics.
You can repurpose the
plastic by chopping it into
small pieces- but
it will never melt.
Olivia: Okay- so the
thermoplastics are like
ice cubes- I can melt them and
refreeze them into different
shapes whereas the thermosets
are like a raw egg –
once I cook it- it can
never be a raw egg again
Polly Mer: Exactly!
Narrator: Make
the thermoplastic:
Polyvinylchloride, PVC!
Olivia: Here we go!
Narrator: Make your PVC Blue!
Olivia: I hadn’t
thought about that-
plastics do come in all colors.
Narrator: Make your
plastic more light weight!
Add some filler!
Polly Mer: Fillers make the
plastic lighter, reduce costs,
stabilize, and sometimes
make them somewhat fire proof.
Narrator: Your PVC
is too brittle!
Plasticize it!
Olivia: I thought we
just made plastic!
Polly Mer: Plasticizers are
chemicals added to the mix of
monomers to give the
plastic different properties.
Phthalates are chemical
plasticizers that are used in
PVC to make them more flexible.
Olivia: Finally!
Weird!
It smells funny!
Polly Mer: Those are the
plasticizers escaping the
plastic – they can
be health hazards.
Narrator: Make the
thermoset plastic: Bakelite
Olivia: Weird!
This time our
ingredients are liquid!
Polly Mer: Yes, remember these
types form covalent bonds
between polymer strands
after they cure or set.
They are usually in liquid form
to begin with and over a period
of time will become
a hard solid plastic.
Many of these are
used as coatings- like
polyurethane on furniture.
Narrator: Polymerizing.
Time remaining: 24 hours.
Olivia: 24 hours!!!!
Guess I’ll check
on that tomorrow.
Polly Mer: Time to
feed the fungus!
Olivia: Pardon me?
Polly Mer: This may be
a Plastic Farm – but
we still have critters to feed!
This fungus is one of the few
species of fungi and bacteria
found to digest synthetic
polymers like plastics.
But they only decompose specific
plastics in specific conditions–
so they are not enough to
save earth from plastics
that are not recycled.
That one wants PVC.
Olivia: So humans CAN choose
to produce some plastics that
will be better for the planet!
Narrator: 6 hours later
Olivia's Dad: Olivia? Honey?
What are Farm bills, and why
did I just get a call from the
phone company about a
$500 charge for them?